how are you knowing yeah how you doing
man I'm doing fine is this is I don't
know if you you've probably seen one of
these things is this is this you is this
based off of you with I black and um I
maybe I honestly I've never seen this
before the only reason why I've seen is
get struck at it and he gave it to you
and I watched that interview but uh okay
I only will check the only one that had
things like that earlier well it's
definitely on him because there's not a
mullet there's no party in the back on
this thing underneath yeah I mean it
could be any I mean I wouldn't know I
mean I haven't got one of those before I
would really like one now mm-hmm well I
don't mean to put you on the spot Nolan
what would you rather have this rocky
sippy cup or rich eyes and chill mug
come on now a rich guy idn't oh for sure
okay are you just saying that because
we're on the phone right now no no man I
I'm a fan of you man I was definitely I
would definitely level in your cups okay
okay we're on it sold and sold to Nolan
Arenado are are you being overlooked the
Rockies by everybody
Nolan um as a team yep um yeah I'm gonna
do a little bit but I think people are
taking notice now you know I think we
got two months left and we're still in
this and I think people are trying to
notice us a little bit but you know
there's a lot of games left you know we
can't forget that there's a I think just
over 50 games left or just about that
and you know there's a lot of room that
when there's a lot more room to win ball
games and there's far a lot of people
that think we're gonna fail and that's
okay you know we need the doubters and
stuff like that but at the end of the
day we still gotta go out there and you
know we're gonna go perform and we I
will prove people wrong you know the
people doubt us because in the years
past we haven't be able to prove that we
can do it so this year it looks like
things are changing and hopefully we can
continue that well part of the reason I
think is because the Dodgers have just
won an absurd number of games in their
first hundred and seven attempts that
that might be part of it too Nolan how
do you think you guys match up with the
Dodgers should something like that
happen in October yeah I mean obviously
the Dodgers are unbelievable it seems
like they went literally every single
night I think they lost last night and I
was kind of like I got like goose bumps
I was like in so much shock um but I
think at the end of a UH you know
they're a great team you know we both
know each other really well so that you
know there's a little I wouldn't say
comfortability there but there's a
little you know
knowing what your going into when you're
facing certain guys over there but uh
you know they're tough they're a good
team you know right now I would I'm not
saying it's it's a right now they're
they're a little bit better than us you
know I'm afraid that that but uh you
know when it comes to crunch time and if
we have an opportunity to play them
October you know anything could happen
and you know we're good enough to win
and we have a really good lineup and
that's like we can we can match up with
anyone yeah in that regard Nolan Arenado
joining me here on the Richardson show
what is uh the addition of Jonathan
Lucroy from from the Rangers mean do you
think yeah yeah I mean it's great it's
huge for us you know you know as a team
with young pitchers we know we're going
into unfamiliar territory you know at
the end of the day the last two months
you know we're playing really meaningful
baseball games and not a lot of us
doesn't do that um so it would be good
to have a guy that's been through it you
know Luke or you know he's won the
division he's been with the Brewers he's
won there you know he's also been with
the Brewers and you had a tough go
around where they you know they lost
like right at the last end you know he's
so he's seen both sides of the game and
that's something that you need that you
know you knows how to control the
pitchers and he's just a great guy great
great teammate there you go and then you
got Pat Neshek from the Phillies as well
so that's a great picture for you to add
to this mix right here
is there still a humidor in that stadium
out because I saw once upon a time when
I was covered uh the the all-star game
back in the late 90s
Nolan is there still a humidor in that
building for the for the baseballs yeah
yeah there is there's one here I've
never really liked seeing it or been in
it but I know there is one here for sure
so it's it's kind of like Fight Club you
don't talk about it is that what you're
saying the humidor no no it's actually
not talking about too much but uh you
know I think most when other teams come
is they talk about it a little bit more
than us well because I mean do you think
you're do you think your stats and your
your achievements individually people
just put an asterisk next to it because
you're you're playing in Denver Colorado
yeah yeah you know you know that's just
something that thing that just come with
playing out here you know I think Todd
too low Larry Walker you know guys like
guys we've all had to deal with that you
know and at the end of the day that's
okay I you know I'm not worried about I
think
um I think you know the doubt I get is
mostly from you know media and stuff
like that you know I think you know I'm
very fortunate I think you know players
that we play against I think that you
know they respect me and respect the way
I go about my business and respect the
way I play so I think that really means
more to me you know if I have their
respect and I think that that means a
little bit more than what you know the
media says and you know all the doubt I
get from that stuff but so you know when
it comes to that I don't really care um
it means a lot when you you know you go
to play against other teams and you know
they appreciate the way you go about
your business you know that that's when
you know that you know for me that's not
what it's rigged or anything you know if
people appreciate the way you go about
your business and guys I know how hard
it is and you know they face the same
pictures you face and the Kershaw's are
serious and all then and they appreciate
the way you go about it you know I think
that hits home a little bit more yeah I
don't believe the atmosphere affects
your gloves
right no one can know no I just dries it
up a little bit it's got you got to lube
it up a little bit yeah okay
just want to make Gary because you mean
you got the gold gloves I'm just
wondering how you know how it affects
all that a couple more minutes left with
Nolan Arenado Iran the Rich Eisen show
who was your guy growing up who did you
idolize growing up in Southern
California no one yeah well you know
obviously I was a huge belch a friend
when he was at the Dodgers back in the
day um I love Shawn green um I grew up
but unfortunately you know unfortunately
I grew up a Dodger fan and I think that
has a lot of people the wrong way around
here so but yeah it's the truth you know
I grew up I love Shawn green I love
Beltre um you know my cousin's my got
some family matter who Dodger fans so
that's kind of how it all started you
know when we go play in LA
you know they always text me that you
know I hope you get a couple hits but I
hope you guys lose you know no come on
now yeah I hear it all the time so it's
all good
um it's all good but uh yeah you know
that's just kind of like who I look I
love Matt Holliday um I loved his swing
that's coming someone I admire as I got
older - okay
well just tell everybody that says that
to you Nolan that you can't make purple
without blue right yeah yeah I guess I
could say friend or thought about that
but you're right come on now I mean I
remember my primary colors and how you
make colors and you
we all had Crayolas at some point come
on now yeah I know but I guess I have a
little more respect for them you know
the truth those are true fans you know
if they're hoping I'm there I'm on their
blood and they're hoping that we still
lose but I want to get a couple it I
guess you can respect the fact that they
they're true fans Nolan Nolan your red
blood their Dodger blue mixed together
makes Rocky's purple rice about that's
about four I'm gonna send that text out
yes I don't know by the way I don't I
don't need credit not how am i credit
you it's okay and I'd be like some of
them might know who you are but some of
them will know just hold on a second no
look here's the deal you're gonna get a
mug you're gonna get a phrase for me I
don't know what the third one's going to
be before we finish up this conversation
yeah but it's all good brother it's all
good so um you know the next six weeks
here who who's doing the who's leading
in that Clubhouse is it you who's the
one who's going to try and get everybody
rallied together and focus on the I the
prize I guess underneath what the radar
because of everybody focusing on the
Dodgers yeah um I think you know I you
know the baseball sister it's a funny
game you know because uh it seems like
you just kind of let people go about
their business in a way you know you
want people to lead you want to lead by
example and I'm not a big vocal guy
that's not really me I'm kind of more I
just go out there and play and do my job
and I try to be bikeable and I hope you
know I work hard and I want people to
notice that you know I just never been a
big vocal guy um but you know there's
some other guys you know in Desmond
Charlie DJ um you know some of those
some guys go through Corey now you know
the you know there's some leaders we
have and they'll be vocal once in a
while but at the end of the day you know
baseball the sport where you know you
know when you're winning ball games you
know and and in anything starts fall
apart or like you know it's good that a
winning because that means people you
know they have to be on their game you
know like you if you're not working hard
and we're winning but you're falling
apart you know you know the light shines
on you a little bit more so everyone
need to know that they need to do their
part they need to work hard and get
after because you don't want to be the
one causing the problems around here you
know what I mean so we're
we got some young bucks but they get
after it and you know guys are doing a
really good job
all right well Nolan thanks for coming
on the show tell Blackmon he owes me
that Hawaiian dinosaur shirt that he
said he was going to give me off his
back literally when he came in studio
during the Dodgers rocky series last
okay he owes me that uh I appreciate
about Solomon he has a bunch of those
weird shirt I don't he could definitely
send you one okay you don't have that's
not your style no he actually sent me he
actually got me a couple on Amazon last
year and I'd uh I definitely do not wear
okay very good so then he's got some to
spare and we'll send your mug Nolan I
mean I want it because I'm like why are
you want by the way bless well why
aren't you on Twitter because at least
he could tweet out this thing you're not
on social media no no man I've just
never really been into it um I don't
know why I just I think it's just cuz my
all my family members they've had it for
so long and they've always just you know
they've always been all about it and
I've just kind of been like and I'm good
so yeah I think I'm good all right no
one you're good everyone well you you're
better than good thanks for joining us
appreciate appreciate it they can't pay
that's Nolan are not so rich eyes and
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to